wir sind gekommen vielleicht hat das ja
und was wir gerade was ich gar nicht
wusste dass ich richtig erzogen oder was
das war schon sein baby wird immer
sorgen genommen duscher dieser bewusst
und ich hab schon vergessen mein film
fazit ich fand avengers eigentlich an
sich megageil guckt mich an diesem film
kritiker ja nee also ich fand den film
mega gemacht aber ich bin jetzt ehrlich
gesagt wäre der story hat man sich viel
mehr gedanken machen können also einfach
ich weiß nicht was ein bisschen stunden
fährt ein bisschen tiefer gehen können
aber sonst kommen jetzt gerade als sie
das gerade im stress von teils noch
nicht richtig mitbekommen dass piloten
und nehme mir geklaut
das ist peter das ist der master form
von tyson und das ist der hessen
jetzt sagt uns ich habe mich das erste
mal im youtube fifa match gewonnen ich
habe hier gegen patrick habe ich
verloren
die pedale verloren aber diesmal habe
ich nach 120 die gute arbeit das ein
elfer links unten erhöhen etwas
ausgegangen
die grösste schweizer bereich für sich
tatsächlich ausgegangen das ganze
wahrscheinlich so schnell dass ich wenn
ich jetzt noch irgendwas sage zum
spielverlauf weil leute ich bin es
wieder konkreter
das ist das tolle video antwort ich bin
viel spannender als grün
bauleiter ich hab nix gedrückt ich bin
so einfach wird dich nervt schon mit den
ganzen update von den fifa sachen aber
nicht drin
wir wollen gegen den federn muss ich
aber echt sagen gleich mit erschießen
siege sind immer scheiße waren
ich will auch elfmeterschießen siege
sind geschlossen
[Musik]
doch freunde wir laufen uns jetzt gerade
noch unbedingt erneuert in richtung
hauptbahnhof weil wir irgendwie alle
noch immer bekommen es ist graz halb
eins das ist beim musical freunde karten
kosten 43 euro können aber gerne prinzip
was jetzt passiert
freunde wir waren gerade noch schön am
hauptbahnhof das essen und jetzt gerade
haben wir versucht irgendwie mal mit der
bahn gegen den köln voranzukommen
wenn wir dann zwei stationen gefahren
oder zwei stationen sind und es war
wirklich so typisch bahnfahren wird
überall besoffene leute schreien rum
dann wieder in der bahre dachte jetzt
mussten wir gleich weiterhin standen
locker erst mal 34 minuten weil
willkommen auf gleiche höhe luca ist in
wirklichkeit nicht 190 und 190 bin ich
echt das finanzamt ich wusste dir das
ist immer so wenn leute nicht zuerst mal
sehen dann sind sie stehen immer so vor
dir und ich war auch am anfang am anfang
ich weiß gar nicht mehr bei mir aus
gesehen hatten das allererste mal ja ich
war auf jeden fall gerade im
standardtanzen du hast du die mutter
reingeworfen landsleute war auf dem flug
zu tief und ich bin anders gegangen
haben ein kleiner kasten
wir haben hierbei waren gebracht wo eine
art wie wir werden jetzt noch mal
schauen was da noch so mit sich bringt
wurde wie befindet jetzt gerade hier
dass ihr vielleicht schon kennt hier
fand ich damals die faktoren zusammen da
sind mir die ski challenge aufgenommen
durch sich nicolai teams hier vor zwei
wochen oder drei oder vier kann aber das
war es von diesen deal ob ich weiß nicht
ob ich so etwas gefällt vielleicht weil
ich so was man öfters mal in letzter
zeit immer mehr so viel leif kramp
gemacht jedenfalls ist es nun das ende
wir waren zusammengefasst im kino und
danach noch tiefer spielenden youtube
haus und jetzt sind wir noch besser
machen wollen vielleicht noch mister
bean schauen aber gerade ein bisschen
bock drauf und dann will ich sagen es
euch gefallen hat schnitt erzählerin wer
dann vorn und wir sehen uns irgendwann
anders wieder
[Musik]